[تصفيق
] ليس كل يوم أن ترى شخصًا
مبتورًا يمشي جنبًا إلى جنب مع ساق مشدودة
ثم يبدأ في الرقص بالنقر ، اسمي إيفان
روجيرو وأنا راقص نقري ذو ساق واحدة ،
إنه لأمر ممتع نوعًا ما أرقص بالنقر
كنت في السادسة من عمري ،
لقد وقعت في حبه ،
كنت أعرف أن الرقص النقر سيكون دائمًا
شيئًا أردت أن أفعله
لبقية حياتي عندما كان عمري 19 عامًا ،
كنت أعاني من ألم في ساقي اليمنى
سرطان العظام ساركوما العظام
، وفي 21 مايو 2010 ، بترت ساقي اليمنى
فوق الركبة ، كنت
مدمرًا ،
لقد اعتقدت للتو أن راقص الصنبور يتم
تشخيصه بسرطان في ساقه.
طريقة راقص النقر في اليوم الذي
تعرفه لولا تلك اللقطات
لم أكن لأتخيل مطلقًا أنه يمكنني النقر على
الرقص مرة أخرى عندما أضع ساق الراقص
تلك لأول مرة وبدأت في صنع
تلك الإيقاعات التي شعرت أنها جزء مني  التي
عادت وشعرت وكأنني نفسي القديمة
كنت أب  لتعليم نفسي كيفية الرقص
مرة أخرى ، لقد تركت ذاكرة العضلات تعود إلى الوراء
وحاولت ألا أفكر في القيام
بخطوة خطوة بخطوة بساق
الوتد فقط مع ربط قفزة الوتد وتغيير
مفردات الخطوة التي أؤديها في
نيويورك  المدينة كانت هناك بالتأكيد
شهقة مسموعة في الجمهور مرة أو
مرتين أثناء خروجي على خشبة المسرح
[تصفيق]
رقص النقر هو أمر شخصي للغاية ، إنه
يتعلق كثيرًا بالمشاعر التي يمكنك في كثير من الأحيان
معرفة متى يكون راقص النقر سعيدًا من
قبل  الطريقة التي يرقص بها على الرغم من
تشخيص إصابته بالسرطان ، تمكنت من
التغلب على ذلك وتمكنت من العودة
إلى الأشياء التي أحببتها كثيرًا ،
لذا ستكون دائمًا
عاطفة مختلفة تمامًا مرتبطة
بالشكل الفني
[الموسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]